now
[Applause]
activists and far-left lawmakers
outraged over the death of a homeless
man on the New York City subway graphic
video showing a U.S marine putting
30-year-old Jordan Neely in a Chokehold
after Witnesses say that Neely was out
of control throwing garbage and
threatening other Riders Manhattan D.A
Alvin Bragg is now investigating what
happened after the city's medical
examiner ruled the death as a homicide
police confirming that the homeless man
had more than 40
prior arrests and reportedly had an
active warrant out for felony assault
the Marine taken into custody after the
incident but was later let go without
any charges at this time Squad lawmakers
lashing out against the Marine
AOC calling him a murderer Jamal Bowman
describing it as a public execution and
Ayanna Presley says the death was a
lynching
but mayor Eric Adams sings these
comments are out of line
I don't think that's very responsible at
the time where we're still investigating
the situation let's let the DEA uh
conduct this investigation with the law
enforcement officials uh to really
interfere with that is not the right
thing to do and I'm going to be
responsible and allow them to do their
job and allow them to determine exactly
what happened here so we cannot just
Blakely Blakely say what a passenger
should or should not do in a situation
like that we should allow the
investigation to take his course
Sudbury crime is a big problem for New
York City so far this year there have
been 139 robberies 131 felony assault
one rape and one murder and we've shown
you countless videos of attacks on
commuters critics blasting AOC for not
even commenting on those crimes and
pointing out how the congresswoman
dismissed the idea of adding more cops
to the subway
Subway crime is up but let's also note
that Subway crime is up after they
committed
so many more officers to the subway
system so that also tells us from a
policy perspective adding more cops to
the subway isn't solving this problem so
there are other things that can solve
this problem
she's not taking the subway you don't
take the subway to the Met Gala and she
I we asked the brain room today has she
commented at all on any of the other
crimes remember for example the women
who have been attacked turns out answer
is no no if there's a race Factor that's
when she pipes up I have a lot of
respect for Eric Adams after listening
to that statement a lot of respect you
don't know what someone's capable of and
when you're trapped in a box throttling
through Manhattan underground and this
is what this guy was screaming according
to Witnesses I want food I'm not taking
no for an answer I'm ready to go back to
jail I'll hurt anybody on this train I
don't care if I get a big life sentence
I'm ready to die you're about this close
to someone like that and he's crazy
mentally ill he's an ex-con if you're a
marine you're trained differently you're
not a regular citizen you have training
and that training kicks into gear and he
it looked like was trying to engage this
man at first at first verbally and then
it got physical and he was trying to
restrain him it was an accident he was
not trying to kill this person he was
trying to restrain them subdue him and
other men joined in him in restraining
this guy it looks like what happened was
an absolute tragedy the guy obviously
doesn't deserve to die like that and we
wish it didn't have to be a marine
stepping up we wish a police officer had
been there AOC famously said she didn't
want any police in the subway if a
policeman had been in that subway car
this would not have happened I blame
this guy's father who's not in the
picture the mother is passed away the
city says they care so much about mental
health and they let mentally ill people
wander the streets threatening people
he's been arrested 40 times and had a
warrant out how many judges let this guy
skate so
I wish AOC would ride the subway once or
twice just to get a Vibe because I'm
hearing from a lot of women today not
women from all over the country
specifically women that take the subway
in New York City
and they think about this a little
differently than other people and they
know what it's like and they're not
saying I'm glad this guy died they said
finally a man stepped up in the subway
and protected us
I absolutely agree with that and you
know a lot of people Greg that take the
subway are ones that you you don't have
a choice uh you're coming there's a way
to get into the City and it's the most
efficient way or the most the least
expensive way to be able to get into the
city for jobs that AOC would never do
yeah anybody who's I I rode the subway
for years until it became unsafe I've
been in that situation and and what
everybody does is essentially try to
mind their own business or get off the
train and then I luckily I've never been
in a situation where it gets that that
violent but this feels like a Bernie
gets moment where everybody goes okay
we're hitting the bottom here this is
bad permission to rant sure anyone
accusing anyone else of supporting that
guy of of non-compassion can go screw
themselves right we've been talking
about what's going on in the Subways
we've been talking about what's been
going on the streets uh the mentally ill
being left to suffer on the street the
criminally deranged left on the street
to attack and push women in front of
trains and beat people over the head
with pieces of wood we've been talking
about the danger to themselves and the
dangers to others for years and I have
nothing but contempt for the outraged
leftist who caused this who ignored this
they are like the person on the subway
who just gets on the their phone and
it's something like I wonder I wonder
would would AOC or anybody on the squad
or what's his name Chris Hayes anybody
like that would they actually step in
right I have to wonder would they
actually you know would they see
somebody being menaced by a violent
felon would they actually try and
intervene or would they decide not to
share the risk and just step away
because metaphorically that's what
they've been doing for the last five
years so they're disgusting uh if
anybody says this is like George Floyd
no it's because of George Floyd because
since George Floyd we've had the
resulting chaos the defunding the
emasculation of the police uh egg on by
the squad by the media by different
media Outlets except CNN they that
created the pathway and a void where you
sought fewer police and you have and who
had to fill the void and we predicted
this citizens were going to fill the
void we were going to talk we didn't use
the V word because everybody hated that
word but what was going to happen was
there was going to be a moment where
somebody has to make a choice so about
those bystanders I think there are three
guys and I don't think they were all
white right I don't know they had to
make a decision on their own there was
no police they were adult men it was on
them a chance to act and it was and they
chose to act and I support the fact that
they thought people were in trouble uh
the left is emasculated law enforcement
these are the only people you can rely
on the message is if you can't rely on
them you can't even take the subway
anymore uh this was a textbook person
that would have been helped by the 800
million dollars that somehow disappeared
right there's there's money in this city
for the homeless what did the de blasios
do with it this guy had 40 arrests
violence he was a danger to others and
when he's a danger to others he becomes
a danger to himself hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else